congressional Democrats call two star
witnesses to testify in the impeachment
hearing ambassador to Ukraine William
Taylor and Deputy Assistant Secretary of
State George Kent meanwhile Republican
Jim Jordan reduced them both to a
sputtering pile of mush in about 25
seconds we will examine everything you
need to know about impeachment then a
surprisingly sensible take on
transgenderism from a notoriously
senseless source Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton unbelievable we will analyze the
left's gender fault lines finally the
mailbag all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
by the way I want you to know I'm
considering titling my next best-selling
blank book everything you need to know
about impeachment because you don't need
to know anything about impeachment
because it's a complete force and we
found out that it was a force today I
guess it that's it's not quite true it's
worth knowing exactly what's happening
in the impeachment hearing just so you
can see how transparently political
naked leap artisan hacky this whole
thing is it has no basis in the law no
basis in the Constitution no basis in
reality whatsoever who are the key
figures the star witnesses that the
Democrats called forward today that
we're supposed to sink president Trump
to guys ambassador bill Taylor he was a
soldier he worked as a legislative
assistant for the Democratic Senator
Bill Bradley and then he worked at the
State Department under Bush and Obama he
is key here because ambassador Taylor
ambassador to Ukraine had texted the
ambassador to the European Union Gordon
Sundlun
and asked him are we now saying that
security assistance and White House
meeting are conditioned on the
investigations into Biden so he's the
one who texted the ambassador to the EU
to say is there a quid pro quo more or
less now what's funny is we already have
testimony from sunland that there isn't
a quid pro quo and that this is all just
a big misunderstanding but anyway that
is how ambassador Taylor fits into this
the other guy who fits in is George Kent
George Kent is Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State for European and
Eurasian affairs and he is a career
foreign service guy now ambassador
Taylor opens this up and if he's gonna
be the star witness right so ambassador
Taylor should come out there and just
say here it is I've got the smoking gun
here's the evidence the president Trump
engaged in some corruption and here's
how I know it and here's what I saw on
what I heard but it can't do that
because ambassador Taylor didn't see or
hear anything
he has no first-hand information
whatsoever in fact as he pathetically
revealed today in this testimony before
the Democratic Council Daniel Goldman he
can offer the impeachment inquiry
absolutely nothing other than
tell them what he heard from other
people mr. Govan what I can do here for
you today is tell you what I heard from
people and in this case it was what I
heard from ambassador Solomon okay so
that was a perfectly honest statement
and at the end of that statement I think
everybody should have gone home because
he said well look I'm here to testify
about some rumors that I heard and a
bunch of hearsay and so I don't know why
you didn't get the people that I
allegedly heard all this from but all I
can do is pedal in hearsay and rumors
okay I guess we're finished here right
but it's the best they've got
I mean this is he is the star witness
because he's the best that the Democrats
have it did not take very long for the
Republican Jim Jordan who is just
terrific at ripping these guys apart in
testimony to pretty much reduce
ambassador Taylor to a pile of
mealy-mouthed mush let me read it one
more time a master tailor recalls that
mr. Morrison told ambassador Taylor that
I told Mr Morrison that I conveyed this
message to mr. Sharma on September 1st
2019 in connection with vice president
pence his visit to Warsaw and a meeting
with president Solinsky we got six
people having four conversations in one
sentence and you just told me this is
where you got your clear understanding
which I mean even though you had three
opportunities with president Solinsky
for him to tell you you know what we're
gonna do these investigations to get the
aid didn't tell you three different
times never makes an announcement never
tweets about it never does to see an
interview
ambassador you weren't on the call were
you the president you didn't listen in
on president Trump's call and president
lessees call either Dodd you've never
talked with chief of staff Mulvaney
I've never did you never met the
president that's correct he had three
meetings again with szalinski and didn't
come up and two of those they had never
heard about as far as I know president
there's no reason for presidents liske
never made an announcement this this is
what I can't believe and you're their
star witness you're their first witness
but you're the guy based on this based
on I mean I've seen I've seen church
prayer change that are easier to
understand than this Oh
devastating devastating and I actually
don't even really mean to attack William
Tayler here the ambassador he's being
dragged before this committee I don't
think he's exactly eager to do it he
doesn't come out of this thing looking
all that great he looks like he has
nothing to say because he does have
nothing to say and Jim Jordan gets to
the heart of it you weren't on the call
you have no first-hand knowledge of
anything you don't know anything about
the quid pro quo and actually you've
never even met Donald Trump in your
whole life is that right yes that's
right but you heard about it from a guy
who was at a coffee shop on the phone
with another guy who read a newspaper
about a third guy that none of it really
strikes anybody as the bombshell
testimony that we were all waiting for
because there's nothing to offer so Jim
Jordan puts it all into stark light and
and what the Democrats are hoping for
here is that you won't watch these clips
you won't listen to reports about this
you won't read any of the testimony
you'll just hear the cloud of
impeachment and you'll just assume that
because the fancy people on TV who wear
suits and neckties are telling you with
a very straight face that the president
has to be removed that you will come to
agree with that as well that's what
they're banking on it doesn't matter as
far as they're concerned if these guys
have nothing to say it's just got to be
the illusion of having something to say
and Jim Jordan is not going to allow
that cloud of vagueness to persist he's
gonna cut to the issue and he does
finish the job in this exchange before
we get to that I have got to thank our
friends over at quip speaking of clarity
look at my clear teeth it is very
important to have nice clean hygienic
shiny white teeth and look I'll be
honest with you I'm not hulking Adonis
of a man but one thing that I've had
going for me are my chompers this is
where quipped the makers of quip
electronic toothbrushes come in I used
to use a non electronic toothbrush I
mean it's basically like brushing your
teeth with a stick it doesn't do all
that much really your teeth just do not
feel clean they do not get white I've
now been using electronic toothbrushes
for four years and equip is so
tremendous because it's sleek it looks
great it's easy to travel with quips
electric toothbrush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a
and even clean quit makes it easy to
stick to a healthy brushing habit that
starts with the electronic toothbrush
and the refillable floss and their anti
cavity toothpaste the quit floss
dispenser comes with pre-marked string
so that you can use just enough I
actually do floss um one of the few
people at least one of the few men I
know who actually does floss regularly
but when I do it because I don't really
I'm not that good at it I'll just pull
like seven yards of floss out and I
don't use it properly
quit makes it so easy plus quick
delivers fresh brush heads floss and
toothpaste refills to your door every
three months with free shipping so your
routine is always right you don't need
to worry about going to the drugstore
you ran out of toothpaste and you're
trying to squeeze the last little cubic
millimeter of toothpaste out like you
know you don't have two pennies to rub
together just make it easy on yourself
don't get into that join over 3 million
healthy mouths and get quit today
starting at just $25 and if you go to
get quick calm slash michael mi CH AE l
right now you will get your first refill
for free merry merry christmas from me
to you that is your first refill free at
get quick calm slash michael that is
spelled GE t qu i p.com slash michael mi
CH AE l quip the good habits company so
Jim Jordan cuts through all the
vagueness that the left is banking on in
this impeachment stuff gets to the heart
of the matter and then while he's
interrogating ambassador Taylor he
finishes the job ambassador Taylor
recalls that mr. Morrison told enough
again this is I hereby swear and affirm
from Gordon Sandlin master Taylor
recalls that mr. Morrison told
ambassador Taylor that I told Mr
Morrison and I conveyed this message mr.
Yarmuth on September 1st 20 the Sall
happens by the way this all happens by
the way warsaw vice president pence
meets with presidents Linsky and guess
what taylor a didn't talk about any
linkage either time the gem is expired
so they didn't talk about it right this
is the issue even though you're the left
isn't making all of these insinuations
and trying to become psychics and read
the motives of the president there is no
hard evidence of certainly of any crime
there's no hard
evidence of any abuse of power there's
no hard evidence of any quid pro quo not
only is there not evidence of an
impeachable offense they can't even find
that hard evidence of nail
administration which is not impeachable
and you can read that in the federalist
papers but they can't even find evidence
of that it's all a bunch of nothing then
again while talking to the Democratic
Council Daniel Goldman Daniel Goldman
trying to get anything trying to give
some clip that the Democrats can use in
this impeachment inquiry William Taylor
admits that there's no quid pro quo
avascular Sandlin says to call him after
you wrote that did you in fact call him
I did and What did he say to you you
said that I had I was wrong about
president Trump's intent that there was
no quid pro quo and but did he say
anything after that what hmm
can you change your answer please
ambassador I'm gonna give you one more
opportunity ambassador to just
completely change your answer because it
really throws them off so this whole
reason the Taylor's here Taylor is the
guy who sends the text to Sunland saying
are you telling me there's a quid pro
quo going on here and Sandlin says call
me because obviously there was some
confusion and what the Democrats were
hoping is the tailor would say and then
we found out that this dirty crook Trump
was selling out the country and
investigating his political rivals in
exchange for funding and but what does
Taylor say instead says he I called
Sunland and Simon told me that I was
misunderstanding this and there's no
quid pro quo and then this port this
democratic councils jaw just dropped and
he was very very upset Taylor in his
initial read of the situation was wrong
that's what it comes down to and he even
admits it himself
bastard Taylor the gentleman asked if
you could be wrong were you wrong when
you said you had a clear understanding
that President szalinski had to commit
to an investigation of biden's before
the a got released and the a got
released and he didn't commit to an
investigation
mr. I was not wrong about what I told
you which is what I heard that's all
I've said I've told you what I heard and
that's the point what you heard did not
happen it didn't happen it did not
happen this is the key you see at first
he starts to try to defend himself and
say no I wasn't wrong but then Jim
Jordan comes out and he shows that he
was wrong so the question here is did
Trump engage in the quid pro quo were
you wrong when you said so no I wasn't
wrong in relying what I heard second or
third hand insurance says but that's not
the point
the point is were you wrong about the
thing itself and we actually know that
he was wrong about the thing itself why
do we know that he was wrong about the
quid pro quo itself because it didn't
happen that what the quid pro quo was
supposed to be that Donald Trump is
gonna withhold military aid to Ukraine
until the Ukraine investigates Joanne
hunter Biden but Ukraine has not
investigated Joan hunter Biden and Trump
did release the military aid so there
was no quid pro quo by definition he was
wrong and so he Taylor doesn't want to
just totally come out and admit that he
was wrong even though he's nailed here
so he starts to change the narrative
tries to change what they're talking
about in the first place
Jim Jordan doesn't let him do it you use
clear language clear understanding and
commitment and those two things didn't
happen so you had to be wrong
miss Jordan the other thing that went on
when that when that assistant was on
hold is we shook the confidence of a
close partner in our reliability and
that that's not what this perceiving is
about ambassador Jones expired too much
that's not what this whole thing started
on the gentleman has expired
that's for Taylor did you want to finish
your answer that's good mr. chairman
yeah you know the want to finish his
answer and that omission is an admission
that the guy got it wrong because when
he when Jordan nails him then Taylor all
of a sudden says well what was happening
was we were risking our alliance with
Ukraine and we were making our ally feel
a little bit uneasy and say hold on wait
what are you talking about
we're here
day to determine if an impeachable
offense was committed by withholding aid
to Ukraine if there was a quid pro quo
even and you're just saying that there's
no evidence of that at all so now you
want to turn the tables and say this is
about if we're making Ukraine feel
uneasy not only is that not an
impeachable offense not only is that not
there's nothing wrong with that but
that's not what anybody here suggests
that they're talking about you know that
the left is on the ropes here because
they're constantly trying to move the
goal posts and fortunately we got some
pretty good guys up there on the hill
who are not allowing that to happen how
about George Kent George Kent the Deputy
Assistant Secretary of State Kent
actually admits while he's speaking to
the Republican representative Stephan ik
that he the the investigation rather
that is being requested here in to
corruption in Ukraine and the 2016
election and even the Biden's is
perfectly legitimate so for the millions
of Americans viewing the first
investigation against the owner of erisa
was under President Obama's
administration that's correct
and broadly this is very important you
testified in your deposition that when
the State Department evaluates foreign
assistance it is appropriate for them to
look at levels of corruption in
countries that's correctly and lastly
you also testified that and this is your
quote issues of corruption have been
part of high-level dialogue between US
leaders and Ukrainian leaders regardless
of who is the u.s. leader and who is the
Ukrainian leader and that is a normal
issue of diplomatic discussion at the
highest level end quote is that correct
that's correct and quote devastating
because even if Trump did the worst
possible things the Democrats can
imagine that he did there's nothing
unusual about that there's nothing
uncommon about that there's a lot of
precedent for it it's a part of
statecraft and it's certainly not
impeachable we'll get to what this means
what we'll get to Trump's response we'll
get to the whistleblower on the
whistleblower have the mainstream
media's handling it and what it means
going into 2020 but first I've got to
thank our friends over at paint your
life you know how much I love paint your
life I've talked to you about paint your
life I
it's an amazing product if you want to
give a really amazing gift you've got to
try paint your life calm so what you do
just very simply is you have an original
painting made of yourself your children
your family a special place you really
like a pet that you really like and you
can get it all at a price you can afford
a shockingly reasonable price from paint
your life calm it's a real painting done
by hand by a world-class artist created
from one of your favorite photos so what
I did I had one beautiful huge framed
gorgeous painting made for my
step-brother and his wife on their
wedding in Grand Central
I mean it's so so gorgeous I could not
believe the price on it I mean it's so
so low it's a thousand but it is just a
great deal and it's really beautiful I
don't have that with me it's too big to
use but they but drew because he's
obviously far less charitable and far
more narcissistic than I he just had a
painting made of himself
it's a really amazing painting I mean
that is some immigrants of real oil
painting it's it's a really beautiful
piece of art and it's framed it's just a
tremendous tremendous product and it
makes the perfect gift this Christmas
season so you choose the artist whose
work you most admire you can go and pick
the artist on the site you work with
them throughout the process until every
detail is perfect there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded it's just it's amazing I'm
already looking into it for other
friends of mine at this season it's it's
a really special gift and you're gonna
have it for your rest of your life and
and your friends and family will have it
for the rest of their lives right now is
a limited offer you get 30% off your
painting 30% off guys get it now just do
it seriously it's so great 30% off free
shipping get this special offer only one
way the way you do it is you text
michael mi CH AE l to 64,000 do it do it
right now
text michael mi CH AE l to 64,000 right
now even if you're not sure who you're
gonna give it to her what you're gonna
get because this deal is too good to
pass up and it the product is too good
to pass up
Michael to 64,000 mi CH AE L to 64,000
how did we get to this whole impeachment
inquiry we got to this impeachment
inquiry because of a whistleblower the
so called was I mentioned this yesterday
but I want to just touch on it a little
bit more today this whistleblower is
according to real clear investigations a
young CIA analyst in a 3031
he's a Yale grad he actually left Yale
right when I got there so I didn't know
him but I knew a lot of people who know
him and he worked for Joe Biden he
worked on Ukraine issues for Joe Biden
he worked for John Brennan he's the deep
state I mean he's what you would call
the deep state and he filed this
complaint which was an absurd complaint
largely just based on public statements
the president had made and based on
rumors that he had heard just like we
heard from ambassador Taylor and this he
worked with Adam shifts office to
coordinate this whole this whole hoax
this whole joke this whole circus and
now he's trying to remain anonymous and
shift is lying and pretending that he
doesn't have the identity of the
whistleblower the whistleblower has to
be called to testify I can't wait for
this guy to be called to testify I knew
a lot of these guys a lot of guys who
like this whistleblower if the guy is
who everyone seems to think he is were
young over credentialed they're these
guys who you know went through Yale went
right into the federal bureaucracy and
think that they have the right to govern
this country however they see fit
voting be damned presidential elections
be damned there are the benevolent
betters the self-appointed elites in the
federal bureaucracy who were going to
outlast anybody who's elected and it's
so unjust and it's so unamerican that
guy's got to testify a little bit of
justice though is that there's now a
whistleblower on the whistleblower
according to Fox News is Greg Rhee a
second whistleblower has filed a
complaint with the intelligence
community Inspector General because the
original whistleblower eric Caramella
allegedly quote may have violated
federal law by indirectly soliciting
more than a quarter million dollars from
mostly anonymous sources via a GoFundMe
page so he may have violated federal law
by cashing in on the whistle
the whole thing gets tawdry or
day-after-day first we were told by the
mainstream media of course that this was
a totally honourable wonderful
whistleblower then we find out wait a
second he's a career bureaucrat wait a
second he works for Joe Biden wait a
second he worked for Joe Biden on
Ukraine policy wait a second he worked
for worked for all these guys who have
been trying to take out Trump and who
are political rivals to Trump and the
intelligence community Inspector General
said there were three clear pieces of
evidence that he would have an arguable
political opposition to the president
that he would have an arguable political
motivation just total BS like the whole
thing President Trump in his
characteristically subtle reticent
nuanced way responded to the impeachment
inquiry and he cut right to the heart of
the matter what's going on now is the
single greatest scam in the history of
American politics the Democrats want to
take away your guns they want to take
away your health care they want to take
away your vote they want to take away
your freedom they want to take away your
judges they want to take away everything
we can never let this happen
we're fighting to drain the swamp and
that's exactly what I'm doing and you
see why we have to do it because our
country is at stake like never before
it's all very simple they're trying to
stop me because I'm fighting for you and
I'll never let that happen yeah pretty
much sums it up I can't find a single
flaw in what the president just said
that's what it's about and I I would I
would not believe it you know if it were
if he were making some claims or
covering something up or if he were
really but he's not he's just saying it
very basically how it is the Democrats
are trying to overturn that election and
stop him because they oppose him
politically and they're trying to use
impeachment as a tool they've been
trying to do it since before he took
office they're trying to use impeachment
as the way to do that they're getting a
lot of help from the mainstream media
there's an incredible new analysis out
which shows just what we are up against
and it's just a bad idea I know even
some conservatives think that we ought
to use impeachment more than we do I
don't think that at all I think
impeachment should almost never be you
historically it it has rarely been used
never for something as frivolous as this
and it poses a real threat to the
country then we'll get to shockingly how
Hillary Clinton has something sensible
to say and the mailbag but first I got
to thank our friends over at honey oh
how I love honey honey is a free browser
extension that automatically finds the
best promo codes whenever you shop
online this means you always get the
best deals without even trying on over
20,000 sites such as Amazon eBay Target
and more honey has found it's 10 million
plus users over a billion dollars in
savings
honey supports over 20,000 stores online
and it has over a hundred thousand
five-star reviews on the google chrome
store I've been using honey since long
before they came on the show I've been
using honey since before the daily wire
existed it's so good I don't I don't
know that I could tell you the last time
I used honey because I always use honey
I don't you know I probably easier to
tell you the last time I didn't use
honey which would have been years and
years ago I mean any on anything I went
to buy sweet little Elise's some
sunglasses I just instantly saved I
don't know like 40 percent or something
because honey goes and finds me those
codes I was going out I was buying some
clothing and you you don't even have to
think about it cuz you just to clicks
boom boom it goes up there and then it
just finds you your savings and you're
done if you're buying gifts this holiday
season you need honey seriously you're
throwing money away if you don't if you
are not using honey then you certainly
know somebody who is using honey you
know me and it is just incredible guys
honey can help make sure that you are
getting the best price for whatever
you're buying it's free to use and
installs in just two clicks get honey
for free at join honey calm slash cough
fa c OV e fe fe has effort throwback
join honey calm / cough fa c o v f e f e
so trump says this is all total BS cuts
to the heart of the matter how is the
mainstream media covering it well here's
how CBS News is covering it and there we
have it day one of the first public
hearings in terms of
inquiry against President Donald Trump
are now in the history books some
devastating testimony today from two of
America's most respected diplomats who
have served both Republican and
Democratic presidents yeah it was
devastating testimony for the Democrats
who is devastating testimony for them
but this is what they do I told you at
the top of the show what they're going
to do is regardless of how bad the
impeachment inquiry goes and the
proceedings go for Democrats and you
heard it you heard it with your own two
ears it's going very badly for them but
it doesn't matter because the fancy
people in the suits and ties will go on
television and tell you it's all really
really bad for for the president and
they'll use it to overturn the election
and at the very least because they're
not gonna be able to throw them out of
office they're gonna use it to to hamper
him in 2020 there's a news Buster's
analysis Media Research Center which
does News Buster's comm Media Research
Center did a study of the the network
news return about ABC CBS and NBC
Evening News cap newscasts
since 2017 what they found is that the
news shows cover Trump with negative
spin 96% of the time how do they
calculate that the way they do it is
they take all explicitly evaluative
statements about Trump or his
administration from reporters or anchors
or nonpartisan sources so we're not
talking about when the talking heads
come on the pundits and the commentators
and they they have their own perspective
drawing about the people who are
supposed to be objective and they then
take out the partisan sources they take
out all the neutral statements and they
just look at a value of statements 96%
of them are negative and it's all about
impeachment they're dedicating more than
three fifths of all administration news
coverage on the network's to this
impeachment nonsense they are also using
secret sources because if they used real
sources they would be shown to be liars
so out of 172 news reports the strong
majority of them 59% 59% relied on
unnamed sources for their so-called
facts about impeachment its BS it's
totally bogus and they are counting on
this vagueness on people's eyes glossing
over to put it past the American people
impeachment is a terrible idea we've
used it now four times threatened it
Andrew Johnson Richard Nixon Bill
Clinton and Donald Trump
nobody has ever been removed from office
as president through impeachment Johnson
was acquitted Nixon resigned before he
could be impeached Bill Clinton was
acquitted
now we get to Donald Trump I think it's
a very good thing in this country that
no president has ever been removed
explicitly through the process of
impeachment it's what what that does
what what the impeachment process does
is reduces the role of the executive
which is a co-equal branch of government
and it makes it subservient to the
legislature kind of like what we have in
the United Kingdom a parliamentary style
government the founding fathers of this
country in their wisdom did not give us
that sort of government because that
sort of government is chaotic and less
representative of the American people
and far more radical and far less
conservative we need those checks and
balances and you should not be able to
throw at a president just because you
dislike him politically even if there's
evidence of some sort of crime there's a
very high threshold you're not going to
ever impeach the president over a
parking ticket or for jaywalking it's
got to really be a political crime it's
got to be a high crime and misdemeanor
but but what we're seeing here
you heard the clips yourselves what
we're seeing here is Democrats trying to
overturn this presidency on nothing that
must be resisted that's by the way the
only reason you have to pay attention to
this it's not because it it is
particularly illuminating it's not it's
a bunch of hacks hack Democrats trying
to throw out the president but you've
got to pay attention because you were
gonna be lied to by the mainstream media
about this and it could be really
damaging instead of really dangerous
precedent
shockingly this is unbelievable Hillary
Clinton said something almost sensible
Hillary Clinton was asked on her on her
pre campaign tour I'm sorry I mean her
book tour with her daughter about
whether women should have concerns about
transgenderism and she said yes there is
a legitimate concern
there's a legitimate concern that women
should have this is all relatively new
people are still trying to find the
language forward trying to sort it out I
think in the right mindset this can be
understood but it's going to take some
time FairPoint she says there is a
legitimate concern about women's lived
experience and the importance of
recognizing that and also the importance
of recognizing self-identification so
she's saying look guys maybe pump the
brakes maybe slow down a little bit here
that is very important because in the
very shallow way that this is being
discussed what the radical leftists want
you to believe is that the people who
accept the unbelievably radical
incoherent and brand-new idea that a man
can become a woman just because just by
thinking so that those are the good guys
those guys are fighting for freedom and
equality and justice and that anybody
else who believes otherwise
including people like Hillary Clinton
are on the wrong side of history they're
unjust
they're keeping freedom away from people
that that is absurd we need to pump the
brakes on that we need some checks and
balances in that sort of discourse and
it brings me right before you to the
mailbag it brings me to one of the one
of the wildest things I saw on Twitter
all day worth mentioning it was a
hashtag which said hashtag thanks birth
control I'm sure there are a lot of
young men out there who have tweeted
that hashtag thanks birth control but
this was actually women who were
tweeting thanks birth control and here's
what they said one woman we're not we're
gonna block out their names because I
don't want to embarrass them I just want
to point out how absurd their ideas are
one woman tweeted out I love the freedom
to plan if or when to get pregnant right
now my choice is fur babies meaning like
dogs and cats real babies maybe later
Thanks birth control another different
woman thanks birth control for leaving
plenty of room in my life for all the
fur babies cause honestly that's all I'm
ready for and that's okay the fur babies
will get back to the fur babies in a
second another woman tweets out I love
my IUD form of birth control more and
more each and every day I'm grateful
that birth control has given me the gift
of freedom and then Hillary Clinton
jumped on and she said reproductive
freedom requires access
- affordable contraception and it's
under attack if birth control has
changed your life take a moment today to
say it out loud hashtag thanks birth
control the ladies protest too much
methinks
I'm I don't mean to make fun of these
women I think there's a lot of
loneliness and anxiety and stress and
and incoherence in the culture right now
and it's convinced people that they
can't have children but they shouldn't
have children to say nothing of the
other effects of birth control to
convince them that what's empowering to
women is not to settle down and make a
commitment with a man who's making a
commitment to her and have a life
together of mutual respect and growing
love day after day but what's empowering
to women is to sleep with a hundred men
and basically be used and use other
people and then slave away in some
corporate office in New York and that's
the only way that you're gonna have a
fulfilling life and that's obviously a
lie I mean perhaps you can people find
gratification in all sorts of different
ways but on the whole the data seem to
suggest that that those kinds of ideas
have made women miserable not just
relative to men but in absolute terms as
well since the sexual revolution since
birth control started but I want to
point out this this perverse idea of
freedom what the second fir baby lady
said was thank you birth control for
leaving plain room in my life for my fur
babies not because that's all I want
or desire but cuz honestly that's all
I'm ready for and then you see the other
people Hillary and that other woman
talking about how birth control is
giving you freedom it's not giving you
freedom if you are a grown-up and you're
not ready to have a baby and the only
thing you can really imagine taking care
of is a cat then you're not free it what
this requires is a deeper understanding
of what freedom is freedom requires
discipline freedom requires that your
will is not a slave to your appetites a
wise man once said that he who sins is a
slave to sin which Saviour of all of
mankind said that I forgive I forget a
guy a long time ago said he who sins is
a slave to sin
the lie that we are told is that when we
give in to our appetites that is our
freedom the freedom to pursue our
desires and appetites to no end to eat a
lot of food and do a lot of drugs and
sleep around a lot and drink too much
and whatever but that actually is not
freedom because then those appetites
dominate even our will they dominate
even our own maturity and we're not
capable of very basic things that
everybody who is capable of until
recently because we have become slaves
to those desires slave - and this is
true obviously throughout the sexual
revolution but this true so much of our
culture which is given into a cultural
decadence and we think of that as a way
of liberating ourselves and we find that
when we thrown off the yoke the chains
of traditional morality we have ensnared
ourselves in a far far more difficult
and devastating slavery just a little
observation about a very very stupid
hashtag let's get to the mailbag first I
gotta say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube head on over to daily wire calm
10 bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Andrew Clavin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh so
you get everything and you get the
leftist here's tumblr you're gonna need
it as impeachment goes rolling along go
to Daley wire.com we'll be right back
you know it occurs to me that that that
sort of freedom idea applies to
impeachment as well because the the
appetite especially of the left is to
throw president Trump out of office and
not wait for the next presidential
election and not win it fair and square
just throw them out and and force that
desire on the country they think this is
liberating it's not liberating because
what you have to do in the process is
undermine those great structures of
government the separation of powers the
contemplative nature of our republic and
the reliability of our elections you've
got to throw all of that away in the
name of freedom what you're doing is
taking away the the basic political
freedoms that we've all enjoyed and that
have allowed us to thrive it's a it's a
real trick I mean it's a trick that the
devil plays which is why Jesus talks
about this in the Gospels because we
think that we are pursuing our own
freedom that way and actually it's being
stolen away from us first question from
REM Thai Michael like you I took a
friend for some money at the Trump
victory in 2016 he gave me 3 to 2 odds
my question is would it be wise to
double down I'm curious if Ben would be
willing to place a second wager with you
again Thanks 3 to 2 is pretty good I got
4 to 1 from my pal mr. Ben Shapiro and
I've got the check right in the back on
my set there and it took him 4 400 bucks
in 2016 because President Trump won and
I think you should absolutely double
down now and you don't even need to be
given odds you could take even odds on
this because a president Trump if the
election were held today would win 57
states
anything could happen of course and the
Democrats haven't picked a candidate yet
that the field is looking very weak
that's why Bloomberg and Hillary are
looking at trying to jump back in as of
right now I would say Trump's reelection
chances look pretty good but next
November is a long long way away
next question from Leia I just recently
watched divine plan a documentary about
the alliance of Pope John Paul the
second and Ronald Reagan against
communism it basically showed both these
men believed in God and His divine plan
to defeat that evil I was wondering what
your thoughts were on this idea
Thanks yes Ronald Reagan's faith is
something that has not been talked to
written about very much he wrote a
really beautiful poem called life when
he was only 17 years old about to
Providence more or less in about death
judgment heaven in hell it's a really
profound poem and it shows a probing
mind even at that young age after he was
shot he said very clearly wrote in his
diary that he knew he had to dedicate
his life to God
he was one of the the most faithful men
in public life that we've seen in in
recent years what people get wrong when
they look back especially conservatives
when they look back at the fall of the
Berlin Wall in the Soviet Union is they
think of defeating communism in
primarily economic terms but it wasn't
primarily about economics it was
primarily spiritual Winston Churchill
who Ronald Reagan quoted in his time for
choosing speech against communism said
when great forces are on the move in the
world we learned that were spirits not
animals something's going on in time and
space and beyond time and space which
whether we like it or not
spells duty that's what it was about and
when you look at the evil empire as
Ronald Reagan called the Soviet Union
and and you look at it it's indictment
for its atheism it's anti Christianity
the economic issues flow naturally from
that the protection of property rights
in the natural law but if you just try
to make it an economic issue it just
simply doesn't make as much sense next
question from Johnny my question Springs
from America's greatest quid pro quo the
Democratic delivery of American taxpayer
dollars to illegal aliens do you think
John Roberts will squeal like a pig and
sidon the Mexican government's request
to continue Daka as an American policy
or will he side with the law will the
Supreme is very colorful way to ask this
but the question is will the Supreme
Court overturned daca I think there's a
very good chance that they will
president Trump seems to think there's a
good chance that they will so he's
sending out tweets basically saying that
he won't just deport everybody on NASA
if they do overturn daca he's trying to
encourage them to do that he's smart to
do it because the court has become
incredibly politicized in recent years
particularly by John Roberts actually
who was
Republican appointee even though he
doesn't doesn't behave like that when
push comes to shove the Supreme Court
watches the news and they watch the
election returns and so I think there's
a good chance I'm cautiously hopeful
from Alex my question is if self
marriage is now a thing then what do you
think self divorce will look like people
now are marrying themselves so it'll
look like when they get divorced very
very ugly that's what I think it will
look like no I think actually it's a
sort of profound question put in funny
terms because I think this obsession
with the self inevitably ends in divorce
self marriage inevitably ends in divorce
because a man wrapped up in himself
makes a small package indeed and we are
not sufficient unto ourselves and we
will come to hate ourselves if we think
that we are just the be-all and end-all
we have two ground our identity not just
in our paltry little selves but in God
himself and the ultimate good in the I
am that I am that's the essence of being
it's the only place where you will find
satisfaction in your identity from Kate
given the additional temptations and
many fans infatuation with celebrities
do you think there is an inherent risk
in a married person being in the
entertainment spotlight did you and
sweet little at least I haven't he talks
about this thanks well I guess if you're
if you're putting me on the Z list or
you know bottom of the list of
celebrities then where are all my
groupies that's what I want to know
bring on the groupies Manco all I ever
get are these like really nicely dressed
young Republican types who ask very
articulate questions and go to church so
come on this is not not what I was
promised I do think that there is this
intrinsic risk of any sort of celebrity
and I don't just mean in entertainment
or politics or anything like that
everybody now on social media can become
his own celebrity if he tries hard
enough and it's why you really need to
know who you are and what you think
before it happened I feel really bad for
child stars and I feel really bad for
young people and even in their early 20s
who become minor celebrities before they
know what they think and who they are
and when they're still immature it does
not end very well and you can easily
give in to temptations if you don't have
a very good reason
not to so I think it's a it's a major
major temptation and it's it's simply
not we're unfortunately many people who
were attracted to the limelight or a
little unstable as you may have noticed
and so there's that's always going to be
that way but if you do not know who you
are if you are not grounded in some kind
of transcendent moral order I would
recommend you refrain from getting too
much of that spotlight from Benjamin
who's a better Catholic you were Matt
Walsh this has been a heated debate
among these skinny boys and Matt back
followers thanks you know Catholicism is
so defined in many ways by the guilt the
Catholic guilt that people feel so I
guess the best Catholic would be the one
who feels like the worst and so in all
of my humility I would have to say that
I am a far far worse Catholic than Matt
Walsh see if you can figure that one out
from Todd hey Brook house Knowles what
are you still doing in California if
Florida is good enough for president
cough FA why isn't it good enough for
you would love to see you out here
Thanks I love Florida it's a super great
place but when I leave California I'm
going to the greatest city in America
Mobile Alabama it's pretty close right
right right nearby maybe I'll come come
by and visit from Raffy you recently
rejected the idea of the ideal person as
being alone and one with nature isn't
this a fundamental rejection of John
Locke and other Enlightenment political
theory John Locke is invoked by the
left-libertarians and many on the right
as well shouldn't you be more explicit
about your rejection of Locke and what
your political theory is based on I
thought I had been very explicit I am
certainly not a Lockean I mean there's
to reduce these men to just one idea one
book is kind of silly and there are many
contributions that John Locke made which
I like very much but I do not ground my
political philosophy in the philosophy
of John Locke if I had to pick one sort
of modern political philosopher to to
point to that explains my ideas I would
point to Edmund Burke who is the founder
of what would be considered conservative
political philosophy in the modern era
and Edmund Burke has said that John
Locke's Second Treatise of government is
one of the worst books that was ever
written John Locke the reason that I
reject
his sort of description of the origins
of humanities because they're simply not
true they have no basis in reality and
we could go on and talk about that for a
very long time but primarily what I find
insufficient about that sort of ideology
which is which is liberalism or
classical liberalism is that it's oh so
so overly focused on contracts and
consent and these kind of clinical
exchanges between people that they don't
explain really how things work I mean I
know that these days a lot of people
like to use the term classical liberal
as a synonym for conservative but I
certainly don't do that I wouldn't call
myself a liberal or a classical liberal
I'm a conservative to describe my
politics and a big distinction here
would be John John Locke and his
followers looking at politics primarily
through a lens of Rights whereas I look
at politics like Edmund Burke would and
like conservatives tend to primarily
through the lens of duty and bonds of
affection and bonds of loyalty and love
those are wildly divergent views and I
would encourage people who you know when
I was when I was a young man I flirted
with classical liberalism but I would
encourage people to look beyond you know
just the sort of two or three writers
from the the Enlightenment and look for
more more profound depths of political
philosophy from Brian what do you think
of the French Revolution and would you
like to see France return to being a
constitutional monarchy a la de Bourbon
restoration funny we were just talking
about Edmund Burke I think pretty much
what Edmund Burke thought about the
French Revolution which is that it's one
of the worst events in the history of
the world and and and gave us so many of
the horrors that we see in modernity
today now is that going to be undone by
reinstating some kind of monarch I'm not
totally convinced of that I think France
might be kind of far gone and attempts
to kind of reclaim the glories of the
past like in England for instance have
not worked out very well you know the
tradition doesn't tell us that we can
just go back and pick one moment in
history and return to that without
consequence tradition is an unbroken
sort of thing and so we're going to have
to
to pull the best of what we can from our
own tradition from ourselves to try to
correct this this sort of rotten
modernity that's given us a whole lot of
money and wrecked us in many ways
spiritually last question from Joseph
hello Michael I was an atheist for a
long time now I would like to reconnect
with God I was very interested in
Catholicism I am very interested in
Catholicism and I was wondering since
you're a Catholic if you could make an
argument for Catholicism over
Protestantism thank you sure I would be
happy to you've probably heard many of
the other arguments about the
historicity of the institution of the
Catholic Church and of the unbroken line
of succession from Peter through all the
Pope's and you've probably heard
arguments over many of the objections
that our Protestant friends make so I'm
really not going to focus on that and
I'd like to focus on an argument that
really convinced me because I came back
from atheism through many Protestant
philosophers I really bear no ill will
toward Protestant philosophers and
people who are who are exploring those
ideas however I did land on Catholicism
and I think a lot of it comes to the
nature of symbol so one big difference
between Protestants and Catholics as
Catholics believe that the host the
communion wafer the Eucharist is the
literal body and blood of Christ and
Protestants I'm painting with broad
brush but generally speaking don't
believe that they believe that it's just
a symbol and of course the Eucharist is
a symbol but what is a symbol and what
is the nature of symbol when we're
talking about Christ the Incarnation is
a symbol the Incarnate Christ when the
second person of the Trinity takes on
flesh and blood that is a symbol but he
is still the divine logic of the
universe he's fully man and fully God
when we use the word literal as say the
opposite of symbol what do we mean
literal refers to letters and what are
letters letters or symbols what I'm
saying is that there is a relationship
here between the symbol and the
symbolized the the symbol you know what
you know what we're talking about the
word for instance and the symbolized
that which the word signifies in that
relationship
in Christ in the church becomes United
and mankind needs that regular
connection between the physical world
and the metaphysical world between the
world of symbols and the world of the
symbolized he needs that regularly which
we get in the sacraments and we get most
clearly in the blessed sacrament of the
Eucharist it is that combination of not
just abstracting and rationalizing
everything away from what it means but
uniting it together in the real person
of Christ whose flesh is true food and
whose blood is true drink that is I
think for people who are atheists and
who are exploring religion that is a
concept that I suspect you would find
quite interesting that's a concept I
think you might find illuminating and
for people who are on faith journeys
wherever you are in that faith journey I
think that is a real beauty and and a
beauty that that will lead you to a
greater understanding of goodness and
truth and that's what we're all after
anyway okay that's our show i'm michael
knowles
this is the michael knowles show see you
next week
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike or Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there